this is the story of an intelligent man
Gerald Blanchard the savviest Criminal
Mind yet cops feds Interpol chasing him
all over the world it was like James
Bond when's the last time you heard of
anyone's stealing a crown jewel
when I was a kid I was very quiet and I
kept to myself and I studied electronics
and took things apart but he's always
been a little guy he looks like a nerd
poor in Omaha Nebraska it's not the
nicest place to live gangs were super
prevalent things weren't good for us
until I learned to go into the store and
it's fuel
he definitely liked the attention it was
fun initially but became very dangerous
and dark
stereo branching out into different
types of crime we went from a small town
Thief to a money-making machine if you
could Rob the banks why not I study
everything because the bank is being
built he's putting ways to get in ways
to get out of the bay I've never even
heard of anything like this
we had Banks calling us in the dozens
and I was pretty good at it
we formed the task force I knew the
police were investigating me so I would
always antagonize them he sent me
pictures just to kind of poke me he was
living the life he had money keeping
company with beautiful women the Rich
and Famous
I could not fathom my son was living a
double life they're trying to chase me
all over the global Cairo Canada London
Paris Vancouver and Austria and that's
when I saw the star
he was committing crimes that were fairy
tale like it was shocking because we
couldn't explain how he was brilliant I
could have stopped but you always need
that thrill he's got himself into
something he didn't know how to get out
of it I knew I was smarter than them the
SWAT team showed up I was terrified it
became imminent that we had to take him
down this is the stuff that movies are
made of
catch me if you can
[Music]